Transcriber: ÖZGE İŞBECER
Gözden geçirme: Ömer Faruk Zeren
Ya uyanamazsa?
Bir ebeveynin,
ameliyata girmek üzere olan çocuğundan
duyabileceği en kötü, en can yakıcı
en travmatik sözcüklerden biri
bu olsa gerek.
Benim oğlum Emir, bunu bana sorduğunda
5 yaşındaydı.
İstanbul'da alanında çok iyi hekimlerin
olduğu, son derece teknolojik, konforlu,
en iyi sağlık çalışanlarının olan en
iyi hastanelerinden birindeydik.
Oğlum ameliyat öncesi
genel anestezi için hazırlanmaktaydı.
Odaya alındı, ameliyat önlüğünü giydi.
Hafif bir tedirginliği olsa
da genel olarak sakindi.
İşlem zamanı geldiğinde ona
şimdi seni uyutacağız.
Bunu ağzına maske takarak mı
yoksa iğneyle mi yapalım?
diye sordular.
Oğlum bir anda panikledi.
Elleri kolları birbirine dolaştı .
Yataktan kalkıp gitmek istedi.
Bana doğru döndü.
Anne ″ Ya uyanamazsam? ″ dedi.
İşte bu her ikimiz için de oldukça
travmatik bir tecrübeydi.
Sonunda zorla kollarından tutularak damar
yolu açıldı ve sedasyonla genel anestezi
için hazırdı.
Bu esnada ben de maalesef ki bir ebeveyn,
bir anne olarak çocuğumu yeterince
ameliyata hazırlamamakla suçlanmaktaydım.
Sonuçta ameliyat mükemmeldi,
gayet başarılı geçti.
Ama gelin görün ki eve döndüğümüzde
bizi iyileşme sürecinde bambaşka
bir dünya beklemekteydi.
Emir odadan odaya geçemiyor.
Karanlıktan korkuyor.
Merdivenleri çıkamıyor.
Yalnız uyumak istemiyor.
Bizle beraber uyumak istiyor ve çok basit,
grip gibi hastalıklarda bile
doktorlara ve hastaneye gitmekten son
derece kaçınır hale gelmişti.
Bu iki dakikalık tecrübe her ikimiz için
de kalıcı izler bırakmaya başlamıştı ki
ta ki Greman bizim hayatımıza girip bizim
bu kaygılarımızı, korkularımızı büyük
ölçüde hafifletene kadar?
İşte benim sıfır noktam
oğlumla yaşadığım bu tecrübeyle
beraber başladı.
Ben bir diş hekimiyim,
ortodonti uzmanıyım.
Aslında hepinizin dişleri sıralayan doktor
olarak bildiği işi yapmaktayım.
Bizim işimizin amacı sizleri daha çok,
daha güzel ve daha sağlıklı gülümsemenizi
sağlamak.
Biz ortodontistler kendimizi gülüş yaratan
hekimler olarak tanımlarız.
Ama gelin görün ki benim de hastalarım
arasında oğlumun yaşadığı travmaları
yaşamış olan çocuklar sıklıkla
karşıma çıkmakta.
Onları tedavi, teşhis değil, onları
tedavinin içine sokabilmek, onların
güvenini kazanabilmek benim için en büyük
zorlandığım şeylerin başında geliyor.
Acaba bizler eğitim hayatımız boyunca
mükemmel bir tedavi yapmak üzere eğitildik
ve hepinizin bildiği gibi bir diş hekimine
gittiğinizde tedavinin ya öncesi
sonrasına ya da en iyi ihtimalle
sürecin belirli bir bölümüne
odaklanmak üzere eğitildik.
Ama bu esnada mükemmel bir tedaviyi
yaparken acaba bazen hastalarımızda ileri
boyutta kaygıya dönüşebilecek korkulara,
fobilere, travmalara sebep oluyor
olabilir miyiz?
Acaba bizler hastalarımızı güldürmeye
çalışırken onlar benden korkuyor
olabilir mi?
Doktor korkusu kaygısı dediğiniz zaman
insanların ilk aklına gelen ne
biliyor musunuz?
Diş hekimleri, bizler; ve diş hekimi
dediğimiz zaman sizlerin aklına
ilk ne geliyor örneğin?
Güzel bir gülümseme mi?
Yoksa acı, kaygı, korku, kaçınma mı ?
Maalesef ki hastalarımız
bizden korkuyorlar.
Onların aklına gelen ilk şeylerin başında
korku, kaygı, kaçınma geliyor.
Oysa çocuk hastalarımızda
böyle bir tecrübe yok.
Peki bizler bu konuda ne kadar sorumluluk
alıyoruz diş hekimleri olarak?
Biz hastalarımızı güldürmeye çalışırken
onlar bizden korkuyor olabilir mi?
Evet, maalesef ki çocuk ve ergen
hastalarımızın yüzde 74′ü yani
kapıdan içeri giren her dört hastamızdan
üçü bizden korkuyor.
Aslında bu korku, kaygı kaçınmanın,
görünenin ardında çok daha büyük
sonuçları var.
Çocukların son altı ayda geçirdiği
hayatlarını etkileyen kronik ağrılara
bakmışlar ve bu kronik ağrı o kadar fazla
oluyor ki okula gitmemelerine en büyük
sebep oluyor.
Bir numarada ne var biliyor musunuz?
Ne üst solunum yolu, ne alt solunum yolu,
ne de başka bir ağrı.
Kronik diş ağrısı. Çocuklar çürük dişe
bağlı olarak kronik diş ağrısına bağlı
olarak ülkemizde ve dünyada farklı gelir
gruplarında olsa dahi 32 milyon ders
saatini kaçırıyorlar.
Çocuklar dişleri ağrıdığı
için okula gidemiyorlar.
İyi beslenemiyorlar, iyi uyuyamıyorlar,
büyümelerine etki ediyor ve akran
zorbalığına dahi uğruyorlar.
Ağızlarındaki çürük dişlerin
genel görünümü açısından.
Ve sadece çocuklar mı etkileniyor
zannediyorsunuz?
Hayır.
Bir çocuk okula gidemediğinde evde
kalacak ve evde kim onunla ilgilenecek?
Aynı zamanda evde çalışan anne babaları,
bizler ebeveynleri veya ondan büyük veya
küçük olan ablaları, abileri, kardeşleri
bundan etkileniyorlar.
Peki bizler diş hekimleri olarak ben
oğlumla yaşadığım bu tecrübeden sonra
sıfır noktasından sonra sahnenin öbür
tarafına geçtiğimde sordum; bizler bu
konuda ne kadar sorumluluk alıyoruz diye.
Çocuklar ve ergenlerimizin
yaklaşık 4 kişiden 3′ü bizden
korkuyor dedik ve bunun en fazlası hangi
yaş grubunda biliyor musunuz?
6-7 yaşları.
Yani erken çocukluk döneminde.
Yani biz ortodontistlerin hastaları ilk
görmemiz gereken, ilk muayene etmemiz
gereken yaşlarda.
Bunu şöyle diyebilir miyiz?
Biz ortodonti uzmanları olarak çocuk
hastalarımızın genel diş hekimi,
algısını şekillendirebiliyoruz
diyebilir miyiz?
Kesinlikle evet.
Biz ortodontistler 6-7 yaşlarında ilk
muayene ettiğimizde çocuklarımızın genel
diş hekimi algısını çok büyük
oranda şekillendiriyoruz.
Peki bunu nasıl yapıyoruz?
Grip olduğunuzda aşı oluyoruz
değil mi grip olmamak için?
Ya da kızamık, kabakulak, suçiçeği gibi
çocukluk hastalıklarımızda
enfeksiyonlu hastalıklarda bunları daha
rahat, daha hafif atlatabilmek
için aşı oluyoruz.
Peki hiç diş hekimliğinde aşı
etkisini duymuş muydunuz?
Bizler 6-7 yaşlarında çocuk ve ergen
hastalarımızda küçük yaşlarda olumlu veya
nötr bir diş hekimi hikayesi, diş hekimi
tecrübesi yaşattığımız zaman
onları aşılamış oluyoruz bir nevi.
Yani onlar ilerde yetişkin olduklarında
istedikleri kadar travmatik bir tecrübe
yaşasınlar bizden korkmuyorlar.
Bu çok çok önemli.
Yani şunu diyebilir miyiz?
Çocuk hastalarımızda böyle bir korku,
kaygı yok normalde çünkü aslında.
Bizler yetişkinler,
ya yaşadığımız tecrübelerden ya da kendi
geçirdikleri travmatik tecrübelerden
dolayı bu korku kaygıyı hissediyorlar ve
biz onları aşılayarak olumlu, hiç korkusu,
kaygısı olmayan çocuklarımızı aşılayarak
yani nötr veya olumlu pozitif
bir muayene geçirerek onları
aşılamış oluyoruz
ve güçlü çocuklarımızı yetiştirmek,
sizce yarınlardaki yeni yaralı
yetişkinleri onarmaktan çok daha kolay
değil mi?
Bence kesinlikle çok daha kolay.
Peki bu iş için neler yapıyoruz?
Ya da hangi yolları kullanıyoruz?
diye sorduğumuzda Finlandiya’da
yapılmış bir çalışma var.
2006 ve 2017 yıllarında aynı gruptaki aynı
özelliklere sahip iki ayrı grubu
2006 yılında aynı gruba bakıyorlar.
2017 yılına yaklaşık on yıl sonrasında
aynı gruptaki diş hekimi korkusunu,
kaygısını ölçüyorlar.
10 yılda neler değişti hayatımızda?
Cep telefonlarınız değişti, sağlık sistemi
değişti, eğitim hayatı değişti,
bilişim değişti, teknoloji değişti.
Ne değişmiyor 10 yıl içerisinde
biliyor musunuz?
Finlandiya gibi sosyo ekonomik olarak
yüksek bir seviye dediğinizde bu
bulguların aynısı tüm dünyada
ve diğer ülkelerde de var.
Dental kaygı, diş hekimi kaygısı
korkusu son 10 yılda değişmiyor.
Buradan biz neyi anlayabiliriz?
Demek ki biz diş hekimlerinin yaptığı
bazı şeyler yanlış ya da hatalı veya
eksik ya da bu konuda daha farklı
sorumluluklar almalıyız.
Yaptıklarımızdan ya da yapacaklarımızdan
farklı şeyler yapmamız
gerektiğini algılıyoruz.
Ben bir diş hekimi olarak bu konuda
bence öncelikle en büyük hatamız
ne biliyor musunuz?
Çocuklarımızı yetişkinler için
hazırladığımız sağlık ve tedavi odaklı,
hijyen odaklı alanlarla
baş başa bırakıyoruz.
Örneğin bir diş hekimini alın, bir
tomografi cihazını, bir diş hekimi
koltuğunu, o sivri aletlerle ilk
karşılaştığı zamanı düşünün.
Bir yetişkin bile bundan dolayı stres
yaşarken sizler daha dünyayı
anlamlandıramamış olan bir çocuktan bu
tecrübeyi kabullenmesini bekliyorsunuz.
Çok önemli bir teşhis koyacaksınız
hastanıza.
Bir tomografi cihazınız var klinikte ve bu
son derece parlak, beyaz, son teknoloji,
en iyi röntgeni veriyor.
En kısa saniyede, en az radyasyonla,
o tomografi cihazından röntgeni
ve sonucu alabiliyorsunuz.
Ama o röntgen cihazı son teknolojik
olan, çocuk hastanız için
sadece bir mağaradan ibaret.
Onu kıskıvrak kapatacak
bir mağaradan ibaret.
Siz o röntgeni çekmeye çalışırken o çocuk
hastanız sizden korkuyor veya siz onu
zorlayarak tıpkı oğlumda olduğu gibi veya
anestezi altında yapıyorsanız o tomografi
cihazınızın son teknoloji olmasının
özellikleri çok da bir
anlamı olmasa gerek.
Yanlış mı düşünüyorum?
Çocuklar için teşhis geldiği zaman hangi
işlemin, hangi tedavinin yapılacağı
klinikte çok da anlamlı ve önemli değil.
Onlar neyi önemsiyorlar biliyor musunuz?,
kliniğimize geldiklerinde, ilk
önemsedikleri şey eğlenmek ve güvende
hissetmek.
O zaman bizim diş hekimi olarak
yarattığımız alanları onların hayal
dünyalarına, oyun ihtiyaçlarına ve güven
ihtiyaçlarına göre tasarlamanız
gerektiğini düşündük.
Oyun aslında biz yetişkinlerin çok yorgun
iken eve geldiğimiz ve günün yorgunluğunu
atmak üzere yaptığımız bir faaliyet
gibi düşünüyoruz.
Oysa çocuklar oyun ile dünyayı
anlamlandırıyorlar, oyun ile dünya ile
olan iletişimlerini kuruyorlar
ve oyun için çocukken icra edilen
en önemli meslektir denir.
Gördüğünüz gibi bembeyaz duvarlar,
soğuk bir koltuk, sivri aletler.
Çocuklar bir kliniğe ya da hastaneye,
sağlık alanına girdiğinde neyi görmek
istemiyorlar biliyor musunuz?
İşte bunu görmek istemiyorlar.
Onlar kendi, daha dünyayı oyun üzerinden
anlamlandırdıkları dünyayla oyun
üzerinden iletişime geçtikleri yaşlarda,
oyunu onların bu tecrübelerine dahil
etmemiz gerekliliğini anladım.
Onlar bir kliniğe geldiklerinde bir ormana
bir macera alanına,
bir Walt Disney stüdyosuna
girmek istiyorlar.
Onların duygularını değiştirebilmemiz için
yani kaygıyı, korkuyu kaldırabilmemiz için
onların yaşadıkları tecrübeyi değiştirip
oyunu onların bu tecrübelerine içinde
dahil etmemiz gerekliliğini anladık bizler
ve onlar ilk girdiği zaman klinikte
tanıdık olmayan bir yüzleri, tanıdık
olmayan sesleri gördüklerinde bu kaygıyla
doğru orantılı bir skala çiziyor.
Girdiği zaman bizim kliniğimizde çocuk
hastalarımızı ağzında belki telleri olan
bir zürafa ya da ona nasıl diş
ipi kullanmasını gerektiren
bir zebra anlatıyor
ve sadece bu tecrübeler hastalarımızı,
çocuk hastalarımızı mı
etkiliyor zannediyoruz?
Kesinlikle hayır.
Bir Walt Disney
stüdyosunun içine girdiği hissi
yaratmamız bizleri, sağlık çalışanlarını,
hekimleri, çocuk gelişim uzmanlarımızı,
kliniğimizdeki, asistanlarımızın hepsi,
hepimize bir olumlu ve mutlu bir hava
yapıyor ve bu aynı zamanda yetişkinleri,
ebeveynlerini, anne ve babalarının
da daha mutlu ve daha
iyi hissetmelerini sağlıyor.
Onların da kaygılarını , korkularını bu
sayede çocuklarına geçirmelerini de
engellemiş oluyoruz.
Ve diğer önemli bir tespitimiz de
kendinizi düşünün bir doktora
gidiyorsunuz, en fazla kaygıyı,
korkuyu nerede yaşarsınız?
Hasta koltuğuna oturduğunuzda mı
yoksa bekleme salonunda mı?
Bekleme salonunda kafanızda belki
onlarca senaryo kurarsınız.
Hayal ürünü olan bir sürü senaryolar
asıl bunlardır
sizi korkuya, kaygıya,
aslında hayal ürünü olanlar bunlardır,
sürükleyenler ve bizler
aslında buradaki korku kaygılardaki
en büyük sıkıntımız,
hayal ürünlerinde kontrol duygumuzu
kaybetmekten korkarız ve acı verici
tecrübeler yaşamış olmaktan.
Bizler,
hem yetişkinlerimize hem de çocuk
hastalarımıza bu kontrol duygusunu
tasarım ve oyun yoluyla geri
vermeyi amaçladık
ve bu konuda kullandığımız en önemli
araçlardan bir tanesi de augmented reality
yani arttırılmış gerçeklik.
Özellikle uzun dönemli tedavilerde yani
kemoterapi hastalarında yani bizim
ortodontik dişleri sıraladığımız,
düzenlediğimiz uzun dönemli olan
ortodontik tedavilerde anlık kaygılardan
kaçınma değil, bizlere uzun dönemli
alışma ve adaptasyon süresi gerekiyor ve
bu konuda augmented reality bizim için
paha biçilmez bir kıymeti var.
Ne yapıyoruz?
Hastalarımızın çok tanıdığı, bildiği bir
telefon ya da tablet üzerinde klinikten
içeri girdiği andan itibaren, normal,
buradaki kendi fiziksel gerçek dünyasının
içerisine oradaki dijital dünyadan bir
hayvan karakteri, kliniğin içerisinde
neler yaşayacağını, nasıl diş ipi
kullandığını, orada nelerle
karşılaşacağını anlatmaya başlıyor
ve en sonunda kendisi bu süper kahramanla
beraber bir fotoğraf çektiriyor hastamız.
Yani o andaki korku, kaygılar ya da acaba
bana ne olacak koltuğa oturduğumdan
ziyade o andaki yaşanan anını iyileştirip
gerçek anını güçlendirmiş oluyoruz
ve hastamız çocuk hastamız
hem fiziksel gerçek dünyasına hem
de dijital dünyaya istediği şekilde
hakim olabildiği için kendini bir
süper kahraman gibi hissediyor o ayrı,
aynı zamanda sürükleyici.
Evet zombi etkisinden faydalanıyoruz
ama istediği zaman da bırakabiliyor.
Yani kontrol duygusu hastamızda.
Ve en önemlisi bir sonrakinde kliniğe
geldiğindeki amacı hangi dolgunun
yapılacağı, hangi dişinin ağrıdığı ya da
hangi dişini düzenleyeceğimiz, hangi
telle değil hangi işlemden ziyade belki
bir sonraki hayvanla yaşayacağı bir
macera ya da onunla çektirdiği resmi
oradaki bizim tablomuzdan almak oluyor.
Yani kliniğe gelme amacı tümden
değişmiş oluyor bizler için.
Ve görünenin ardında bizim
için en önemli şey,
hastalarımız bizden neden korkuyor
biliyor musunuz?
İçeri girdiklerinde biz onlar için tamamen
bilinmeyen yüzleriz. Bilinmeyen
yüzlerle yani bizlerle karşılaşmaktan
korkuyorlar.
Halbuki bekleme odasında bizlerle
karşılaştıkları zaman,
ve onlarla bu tecrübeyi yaşattıklarında
aslında görünenin çok ardında bir onlarla
duygusal bağ kurmuş oluyoruz.
Ve muayene odasına geçtiğimizde biz onlar
için artık bilinen yüzler, bilinen sesler
olmuş oluyoruz.
Ve buradaki en güzel şey belki mesleğimin
bana en büyük armağanı diyebilirim.
Bizimle büyüyen Masal’ın yüzündeki
ifadeyi görebilirsiniz.
Kliniğe gelip oradan resmini alıp bizlere
bu resmimi buldum, burada ben de varım
diyerek o resmini vermesi.
Halbuki o gün yapılacak kanal tedavisi
vesaire değil onun beynini meşgul eden,
oradaki kaygı olmamış oluyor ve sadece
biz augmented reality ile ağrıyı,
kaygıyı mı elimine ediyoruz?
Hayır,buradaki çok çok önemli olan bir şey
Bizler gerçek anlamda ağrıyı
da azaltıyoruz.
Bu sadece bizim diş hekimliğine
kliniğimizde sadece biz yapıyoruz.
Ama bunun dışında kanser hastalarında
yanık ağrılarının pansumanı da yapan
klinikler de var.
Bunu nasıl yapıyoruz?
Bizler vücudumuzda ağrıyı reseptörler
ile algılıyoruz
ve bu reseptörler sınırlı sayıda.
Sınırlı sayıda olan reseptörleri bizler
dikkat dağıtmada kullanırsak,
o zaman ağrıyı algılayacak daha az sayıda
reseptörümüz kalıyor.
O zaman bizler kliniğimizde çok daha az
sayıda hastamıza sedasyon, ağrı kesici
gibi işlemleri yapmamaya başladığımızı
gördük ve bizi çok mutlu ediyor.
Bunun aynısı yanık pansumanı yapılan
bir hastada aynı şekilde yapılıyor.
Yanık pansumanı yapıldığında ikinci
derece yanıkta, hastanın pansumanı
yapılırken arttırılmış gerçeklik
gösterildiğinde herhangi bir sedasyona
ağrı kesiciye gerek kalmadan
inanılmaz bir şekilde o
pansumanın yapıldığını görüyorlar.
Umarım ki önümüzdeki yıllarda bununla
ilgili bizim kliniğimizden çıkan makale
gibi çok daha fazla makaleler çıkacaktır
ve gerçek anlamda dikkat dağıtma
reseptörü olarak çok daha fazla bir
şekilde kullanılacağına inanıyorum.
Ve bizler ortodonti uzmanları gülüş
yaratan ekipler olarak kendimizi
tanımlamayı severiz ve bizim için en
önemli olan ne biliyor musunuz?
Gerçekten gülen yüzlerle çocuklarımızı
kliniğimizden uğurlamak, burada gördüğünüz
gibi ve hem onlar hem de bizler için anlar
ve anılar yaratıyor olmamız ve
çocuklarımızın diş hekimi muayenesini
tasarım ve oyun yoluyla onların kafasında
bambaşka bir tecrübe olarak
kazımaya çalışıyoruz.
Çünkü bizler sağlık sisteminin
eksikliklerini tümden gideremesek de
bence diş hekimliği algısını onların
kafasında değiştirerek daha özgüvenli
büyümelerine sebep olacak en büyük
oyuncular olduğumuzu düşünüyorum ve
burada Hipokrat’ın çok güzel bir sözü var.
Tıp sanatı nerede seviliyorsa orada
insanlık sevgisi vardır,
iyileştirme isteği insana duyulan sevgi
ve saygıyla başlar.
Ve bizler çocuk hastalarımıza daha
küçücükken değerli olduklarını
hissettirmeye başlamamız lazım.
Onların bir birey olduklarını
hissettirmeniz lazım ve bu sayede bugünün
çocukları, yarının yetişkinleri ve hatta
belki de ebeveynleri olacaklar ve
ilerdeki toplumdaki diş hekimi algısını
onlar değiştirecekler.
Ben ebeveyn olarak sahnenin öbür tarafına
oğlumla yaşadığım tecrübeden sonra
geçtiğimde oğlumun bana ya uyanamazsam
anne sözleri belki de bende çok büyük bir
uyanışa sebep oldu.
Bizler bugünün hekimleri yarınlarımızı
tedavi ediyoruz .
Aslında yarınlarımızın mimarına
sadece iyi bir gülüş mü?
Hayır.
Aynı zamanda daha iyi bir ağız hayatıyla,
ağız hijyeni ile daha iyi bir
eğitim hayatı, daha güzel bir çocukluk,
daha güzel anılar ve
daha güzel bir yaşam verebiliriz.
Beni dinlediğiniz için teşekkür ederim.